vsauce kevin here and you are lying to
yourself basically all day long you
don't even know it and sometimes other
people are conspiring to steer your mind
where it shouldn't go you get patterns
wrong you get numbers wrong you get
prices and values wrong and it's totally
not your fault
right
wrong it's why forty thousand three
hundred twenty is actually greater than
forty thousand three hundred twenty
wait
okay i've got two very simple math
problems here under these papers a and b
choose the one you want to solve choose
right now do you want to solve a or do
you want to solve b go ahead
okay now that you've chosen when i flip
the papers over to expose the problems
you'll have exactly five seconds to
solve the one you chose and if you don't
have enough time to solve it you can
just estimate the answer ready go
[Music]
time's up all right let's be honest
virtually no one was able to multiply
those numbers fast enough at least not
accurately but what about your estimates
we know that 1 times 2 times 3 times 4
times 5 times 6 times 7 times 8 and 8
times 7 times 6 times 5 times 4 times 3
times 2 times 1 are the exact same
problem because of the commutative
property which is like a times b equals
b times a it doesn't matter what order
we multiply the terms start small get
bigger start big get smaller it makes no
difference same result but in a 1974
article called judgment under
uncertainty heuristics and biases amos
tversky and daniel kahneman revealed
that the group who tried to solve
problem a multiplying with the small
numbers first had a median estimate of
512. group b who started by multiplying
larger descending numbers their median
estimate was
2250 over four times higher than a just
because the order of the numbers was
different that seems weird no that's
normal we do this all the time and just
don't know it oh and the actual answer
to this problem is as you may have
guessed 40
320. so both groups were way off each
other and way
way off
the truth
the
fact is whether you started with big
numbers or small numbers you were
anchored into a mode of thought that
depended on your initial information
anchoring is a cognitive bias that
basically sets the tone for how you
think about something and it can be
really tough to break out of it or
consider other relevant factors
like
video game prices i recently got into a
teeny tiny twitter argument about how 70
dollar games now are actually cheaper
than the prices of video games 20 years
ago paying 60 bucks in the year 2000 was
actually 90.69
in real dollars but we've been anchored
into video game pricing even ignoring
inflation we didn't talk about how games
also now take longer to develop with way
more staff and the technology itself is
a lot better with 4k graphics and smooth
frame rates wireless controllers full
games you can buy download and play
basically right away from your couch
without having to beg your mom to drive
you to kb toys at the southside mall in
oneonta an hour round trip in a sudden
snowstorm to get a game you know next to
nothing about aside from having drooled
over the same 10 screenshots in game pro
magazine for the last six spots but
that game was xeno gears
and it was
totally worth it
and anchoring happens with stuff like
movies how a movie opens and ends
bookend anchoring has a stronger
influence on what you think of it have
you ever heard someone say yeah the
beginning and end of that movie were
terrible but the middle was really good
no coin flipping massimo piatelli paul
marini flipped a coin seven times and
the outcome was one of these three
sequences pens heads heads heads tails
tails tails tails heads heads tails
heads tails tails tails tails tails
tails tails tails tails the question is
which one is most likely to be the real
outcome let's say you had to bet on it
it cost you 10 bucks if you were wrong
and if you were right you on 30 bucks
when a group was pulled the top choice
was sequence 2 followed by 1 and then 3
for
all the wrong reasons the probabilities
of all three sequences are exactly the
same because each coin flip is an
independent event with 50 50 odds of
heads or tails seven tails in a row is
just as likely to occur as a mix of
tails and heads in the second series but
since we're anchored into thinking
there's typically an alternating mix of
heads and tails in a sequence of seven
coin tosses we
wrongly believe it's actually more
likely
[Music]
dice i've painted four sides of this die
green and the other two sides red same
betting terms as the coin flip game lose
10 bucks if you're wrong win 30 bucks if
you're right which outcome is more
likely red green red red red
green red green red red red
green red red red red red
when people were pulled choice
preferences also went two one
and three that is weird
none of the three sequences are all that
common because they're so red heavy and
red is only two of the six sides of the
die but our cognitive bias tells us to
choose the second sequence because it's
got a nice little mix a nice i don't
know why why well i did that it's got a
nice little mix of red and green even
though the first sequence is
actually contained in the second one
look at this red green red red red
red green red red red why would it ever
be easier to add an additional throw to
make the sequence more likely
it isn't the more throws you make the
less likely you are to hit that exact
sequence here's the math we're really
just multiplying the odds of 1 over 3
for red and 2 over three for green but
check out the relative probabilities
just one swap from red to green in
sequence number two doubles the
probability of sequence number three and
not requiring that extra green throw in
number one makes it about 60 percent
more likely to happen compared to
sequence number two anchoring costs you
money the next time you're shopping and
you see something that's 19.99 yeah 20
bucks sounds a lot more expensive even
though it's just a penny difference but
that 99 cents also anchors you into
thinking about the price in an interval
of pennies so sales of whole dollars off
seems more appealing look if a car
sticker price is 18 000 even you might
counter with 15 000
even but a car at 17 800 is meant to
anchor you into countering in hundreds
not thousands i began this video with
this multiplication example because it's
the clearest illustration of how
anchoring bias can lead to groups with
the same information just presented
differently to reach totally different
conclusions both of which were
dramatically
wrong
anchoring is a good thing it's a first
impression we have to start somewhere if
we're ever going to process any
information in a meaningful or
efficient way but it can definitely lead
you down
the wrong path and without recognizing
what it is and isn't you just have
no hope of overcoming
its effects
but
by acknowledging anchoring bias you're
armed with the ability to choose how
much weight to give it you can stick
with the good accurate anchors that lead
you down the right roads and you can
transcend those that otherwise would
have caused you to
get it
really wrong
the truth is that depending on the
question the real answer might still be
just
floating around waiting for someone
someone
like you
to finally
anchor it
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you